on met ces bienvenus c'est la présidence
et bada
extraordinaire il est évidemment
accompagné de la première dame danielle
maquereau ou pas la chaudière de
l'elysée comme la surnommait à l'elysée
justement lui sauveront ils sont ils un
tour et d'emploi bertrand houette vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
madame macro on vous a vu pendant la
campagne nous a pas entendus certaines
premières femmes ont décrit l'enfer de
l'elysée parce que vous n'avez pas peur
de refaire cinq ans si votre mari guen
demain avec lui j'ai peur de rien voilà
ça ça c'est une belle réponse
c'est à dire vive la france la
république
la maire
j'ai un sujet
qu'est ce qu'on met en tant d'autres
nuits de noces ce que moi j'ai
relativement l'habitude de dormir la
chipolata 1 d'accord
mais qu'est ce qu'on met pendant la nuit
de noces j'ai une petite collection oui
que j'alimente y compte fait alimenté
aussi depuis nourri voulait dire comme
on en voit ça et vous avez un combien de
photos maintenant une petite centaine
une centaine de photos qui représentent
toujours la même chose où c'était photos
d'art
je ne sais pas si on peut appeler ça de
l'art je collectionne les ré l'airé des
poissons mais je n'ai pas le corps et
d'aquariums elle a passé un bon moment
mais le problème de cynthia c'est que
moi j'ai l'image cynthia dans la ville à
sinsheim trop crié à une grosse mêlée de
ce qui la regarde pas et moi j'ai besoin
d'une femme en classe mais aussi qui
sait se tenir j'ai pas forcément envie
d'une boisson asnières sinon je vais sur
le vieux port et j'en récupère ses vous
collectionnez des fesses en photo oui
oui j'entends bien parce qu'à la maison
après il faut les nourrir et tout s'est
compliqué j'ai un élevage de ré à la
maison c'est compliqué je vais prendre
une la choqué non plus qu'elle se pose
des questions c'est vrai il veut me sers
est déjà la première demie lui non c'est
pas l'optique c'est juste que je suis je
dors comme ça
mais si rigole mais on se connaît pas on
ne sait pas il les hommes qui sont moins
pudiques que d'autres je peux voir tes
pieds ça dérange pas
c'est très bien comme moi j'aime
beaucoup les pieds oui je sais que tu es
fétichistes et non je suis pas
fétichiste j'ai pas petit schiste mais
justement en gros j'aime bien les
pompiers stade jacques en gros mois ci
imaginons par la suite tu vas devenir ma
famille je sais pas focal et vos pieds
un gros mois je vais les voir en passe
d'aller voir directement du milieu de
les voir les gnocchis pour voir si ces
voix là et après si elle sort de la
salle de bain qu'elle est très sexy je
pense que du coup je vais oublier chance
d'être shirt et que je vais dormir là
chipoy les
juges boost à capuche pose ta qu'a pu
voir dans post à capuche il ya aussi il
ya aussi ab scott petite biscotte
relève les voyez je suis en voit souvent
des mines des blagues voilà ça que je
suis toi un peu la fleur qui comme elle
dit elle
même que j'aime beaucoup en ce moment
c'est tu serais pas un mélange de cuivre
d'été lire ce que tu es extra qt
cuivre sur le tableau périodique ccu et
élire c'était indique option
en huit lourd dé quoi la définition je
me rappelais fait rire que lui le gros
lourds a crû
dans le beat box et un à son quand on le
fait aux gens ça les choque un peu c'est
le
sais pas moi
ça en fait c'est ainsi qu'il a fait
faire des grosses basses à des gros kick
donc si on fait de la techno par exemple
je ne serai pas moins
devoir de maths fois que je termine ce
soir sur mon lot
tout
et en parlant de tableau périodique tu
vas pas être le mien que je te plaque au
mur
[Musique]
claire a perforé le poumon est remonté
dans les médias ce temps et on va même
retrouver ce que voulait juste ici en
noir les petit répit tant que les
médecins en plus sentir et de l'air
qu'on va retrouver aussi sous l'aisselle
juste ici où on ne voit pas juste là et
aussi ici donc ce patient s'est fait une
rupture du poumon en quelque sorte tout
simplement se masturbant alors
rassurez-vous il a été mis sous oxygène
il va mieux et pourra reprendre ses
activités un jour ou l'autre mais
peut-être en y allant un peu plus mollo
[Musique]
wallays